deep from the heart of Akron House
Theatre one filmmaker will rise from
video store clerk to the guy video store
clerks worship and answer the question
what with a love child of the 90s the
seventies comic books kung-fu movies and
cocaine look like this every word in
Tarantino movie enter a world of classic
cinema and attention deficit disorder
where the smoke is heavy the voices are
gravely pretty sneaky my life story my
way or the highway and everyone is
always hungry I'm hungry let's get a
taco serving big tamales they can taste
you kid pawnshop station experience all
three faces of cuties career the
critically acclaimed crime trilogy the
I'm just gonna make 70s movies phase the
really long one
and the revisionist history revenge flex
and I hope you liked him all because
he's only one movie away from retirement
oh crap really it gave me right let's
see Catholic you bills is one movie
death row vistors short account for a
full one Jackie Brown is an adaptation
so let's just sex that one two there we
go he's only for movies away from
retirement Hugh read a Tarantino main
character they're probably involved in a
life of crime and they're definitely up
to date on what ever dated pop-culture
references are rolling around in his
head you know like Cain and conch food
silly rabbit tricks are for kids like a
virgin Valley of the dolls
you remember fantastic for the Delfonics
the bellboy with Jerry Lewis Mannix the
mental uncle Batman involving P oh do
you know any of these shows or people
I'm talking about when they suffer a
horrible injustice they'll put on a cool
outfit drive around talkin you know what
they call a quarter pounder with cheese
drive around listening to music
and drive around talking while listening
to music then thrill as they go
undercover we'll be putting on an act
and find themselves in a high-stakes
conversation where someone is not who
they say they are one of them felt is
not what he says
these Enzo dodge baby's ass cops until
the whole thing turns into one big
standoff the elect of the other holding
image to test combine a pistol of you
huh I agree that sight she hears it and
everything gets bathed in more blood
than an Addams Family school play revel
in this one-of-a-kind filmmakers
brilliant dialogue sharply drawn
characters timeless soundtracks in that
the songs are from the same era as the
movie
and depending on how you feel about him
either his incredible talent for remix
in cinematic history or incredible
audacity to Jack the cuy shots from old
movies for himself it's not stealing if
you haven't seen it just as Lucas or BTA
or Guy Ritchie or all of them
so salute a living legend who made some
of the best films of a generation while
influencing some of the worst films of a
generation but he gave women and white
people amazing badass characters to
cheer for and he also gave a bunch of
white guys an n-word pass but he matured
and one of the best filmmakers in
Hollywood history but it's thanks to the
tireless work of one of the worst people
in Hollywood history but one thing's
always been clear uncontroversial and
unanimous about Quentin Tarantino this
man loves a good foot
[Music]
don't be telling me about foot massage
I'm gonna put it master I've let him
give me a foot massage you giving a lot
of [ __ ] got my technique down and
everything I don't be tickling enough
wake up your feet would you give a guy
from your side
[Music]
Oh
some shoes
[Music]
probably starring samuel l jackson
michael madsen Christoph Waltz when he
wants an Oscar movie stars rising stars
fading stars chapters trunk shots red
apple cigarettes that's the way the rich
should taste spittin being all gross
torture one word assassin but imagine
cool they're brothers endured at our
hands extreme close-ups
a movie within the movie
Austin Powers and himself yeah but I
have a foot fetish so it kind of even
itself out every Quentin Tarantino movie
[Music]
did you know that Quentin Tarantino also
directed an episode of ER it's the one
where he and dr. Ross go to Mexico and
kill a bunch of vampires what would you
rather have the force or the magic from
Harry Potter
we'll help you decide in an all-new
episode of power levels where we waste
scientists time
quantifying the things that some British
lady made up at a bus stop check it out
now you squib in a world with no oxygen